all right let's go to leah in grand
rapids michigan
leo what's up hi john how are you
so good how about you i'm doing well
thank you
excellent so here's here's my question
um so i've gone on about eight or nine
dates with this man that i met
online and it's been great good
connection we enjoy each other's company
all that stuff
fast forward a few weeks i find out that
the first and last name he told me
is actually not his name at all and he's
actually still
legally married and has a child
yeah so at this point i'm not really
sure where to go from here or what
type of conversation or questions i need
to even be asking him
because i feel like i'm kind of caught
in a dilemma of we respond really well
we have good connection
but he's married
this may be my favorite call ever um
it sounds like you super totally know
what to do
but you don't want to how come
i'm just very confused there's no
so there's hold on there's super no
confusion
um some guy pretended to be somebody he
wasn't
so he could cheat on his wife and did he
say uh
the magic words did he say um we're
getting separated
yes he did yes so awesome so
yeah he's not somebody to be trusted he
is somebody who is
scamming one or both of the women in his
life right now if he all happened to be
the only two
and then he lied about it how'd you find
out
so when he told me his first and last
name i did some investigating
trying to see if like he was on any
social media or whatever and let's be
honest
all good relationships start with an
investigation so go ahead continue
right so i did that couldn't find
anything that's really weird how he's
not showing up on anything
did it again found his like first and
his real first and last name on his
employment site i thought oh wow that's
weird and it had his picture right next
to it so i knew it was him
this isn't weird this is lying and
deception
you're like wow my house is on fire it
smells smokey
yes it's burning to the ground that's
awesome okay so continue so
you investigate stalked him and then you
found out where he worked what his face
looked like he had different names
and then what happened so i screenshot
it and i
sent it to him and i asked him to
explain did you do that via text
yes i did oh jeez okay so you have a guy
that you're kind of falling for
eight or nine and then you text him
busted then what did he do
and then that's when he gave me the
whole spiel of
well he's legally married but he's going
through a separation
he admitted he does have a daughter and
i asked him
why like why not just be honest
um and he said well i thought you'd
never give me a chance
is that true i mean if he's married then
no i wouldn't give him a chance
i don't want to be dating a married man
okay but you are
and you feel conflicted about it so why
are you conflicted about it
i guess i i'm not really sure what to
even tell the guy because
at this point we have seen each other
since but he didn't bring it up
again so i don't know if i need to be
bringing it up again
i can't imagine this is something he
wants to just talk about all the time
um here's a cool thing you can do um
repeat after me
bye felicia go ahead
bye felicia booyah see that's it
i don't do a lot of good on this podcast
i just did just then
it's it's over the guy is not a
trustworthy person
if is how about this have his wife call
you
and let you know that yes we are indeed
we've been getting separated for a long
time the divorce
is just taking some while because the
lawyers are slowed down because of the
kovids
and it's going to be a minute but yes we
are fully
separated i hope he finds happiness
enjoy somewhere else have her call you
and then you can feel free to just date
around the building
but there's no way that's going to
happen right right
i'm super interested in you though
because you've got you sound like you've
got these strong convictions you sound
like you feel totally ripped off but you
have this
um i wish you were having this
conversation in person because i want to
i want to watch you having these
thoughts go through your your mind and
body
you seem conflicted i don't understand
the conflict here
i think the conflict comes into place
because he
seemed at the beginning like a very
genuine person
he has his life together so i i guess i
never would have thought that someone
like him would do something like this
ah there you go so here's an ugly
crappy part of somebody lying to you
like this or getting cheated on
is not only is there a hurt that someone
deceived you
but you stop trusting you
right you've got to grieve the fact that
you missed it
or that he seemed like dot dot dot or
she felt like dot dot dot
if you go back in well that's not a i
was gonna i was gonna compare him to
jeffrey dahmer and that's probably a
little bit not fair but if you go back
and read some of those things
the guy was a lovely wonderful guy
everyone liked being around him he was
fun and everyone said i couldn't believe
that dot
dot now of course this dude isn't a mass
murderer and all that
so that wasn't fair but yes people all
the time think
i can't believe that they fill in the
blank and the disorienting part about
that is
that you have to look in the mirror and
say how did i miss that what is it about
me that missed that
i thought i was smart i thought i was
could read people i thought that was my
thing
and that sucks have you spent some time
just realizing this sucks this isn't fun
yes yeah how'd that go
i was pretty bummed out because in the
last relationship i was in it was the
same type of scenario where he lied
about having his kid
and then the baby mama contacted me and
told me
yeah so it's just weird that it the same
things keep happening
where it's the dishonesty yeah what apps
are you using
don't tell me but maybe that's a good
place to start
with whatever apps you're you're finding
folks on right
um why did you see him again
after you busted him and he told you
this stuff and then you got back
together you all met up and
then it didn't really come up and you
probably had
some imaginary conversations in your
head about what you were going to say to
him when you finally saw him
and you were just going to wait till he
told you and he didn't say anything and
y'all just
went on with your date and then he just
dropped you off and you went home
and then you were just kind of like
how did you feel going through that time
that space
it was very awkward yeah why didn't you
bring something up
because i didn't really even know how to
bring it up
okay ready i'm going to teach you
um and that's not going to be by felicia
this is another one
um let's see how we can do this directly
yes i got it
why did you lie to me
ta-da and then he'll be like no no no
why did you lie to me
we went out eight or nine times and i
was honest with you and i told you some
things about me i was vulnerable with
you and i said i liked you
and you didn't mention anything about
having a kid you didn't mention
anything about being currently married
like why'd you lie to me i liked you
that's how you do that
okay and if in your gut you know he's
not telling you the truth
don't leah you're like you're worth not
being lied to and you're worth not being
cheated on you're worth somebody telling
you the truth
yeah that's true you are and i don't
even care what happened when you were
ten years ago and eight years ago and fi
you're just worth not being lied to
here's the other thing maybe his story
is true
it might totally be true and
he needs an opportunity to turn on come
super clean
and to say i i freaked out i thought you
would never talk to me this whole
thing's been a mess
i lied to you and that sucks and i
screwed up and i'm sorry
i i just think very few people are not
redeemable
but it starts with people looking
somebody that they love in the eye
something that they like in the eye and
say
i screwed up real bad i'm sorry
but if you're just gonna go see him
tomorrow then you've gotta make peace
with you know what i used to say i
wasn't gonna date a married man
i'm cool with it i'm cool with it i
thought i wouldn't be the kind of person
that dated a married man but
it's all good and that may be where part
of your conflict is coming from
i wouldn't recommend that but hey if
that's
if if that's what your some of your
struggles come from that's where some of
your struggles coming from i don't think
so
i think you're tired of people lying to
you and they're not little lying to you
like i love your cooking and it's not
that great they're not that's not those
kind of lies
it's oh yeah i'm still married oh yeah
i've got kids oh yeah fill in the blank
those are big
and you're slowly giving your heart away
trying to be vulnerable trying to
fall in love with somebody and they're
not being honest that hurts and that
sucks
so i'm sorry but i also want you to
trust you i want you to stand firm in
your values and stand
firm in the things that you think are
right and if somebody pulls a big one on
you like that have the courage to look
at them and say why did you lie to me
answer that question we're not going to
go out anymore i'm not going to hold
your hand anymore we're not going to
kiss anymore
why did you lie to me
and if they give you an answer that's
shenanigans and it's just a box of
doodoo bombs then just walk away and
you're going to be lonely it's going to
hurt and it's going to suck but walk
away
tell the truth even when you do
something that's not smart
not right tell the truth folks good
grief leah thank you so much for that
call
um let me know how the final the by
felicia goes i'm interested to know
how that final conversation goes and
somebody create an
app for great people i'm sure that
exists somewhere i don't have any apps i
create an app for people to meet each
other especially now on the kovids